هل انتحرت ام كانت جريمه قتل محكمه قضيه
حيرت جميع المحققين الذين ارادوا حلها
حادثه غامضه راحت ضحيتها شابه كنديه في
الولايات المتحده
ورغم مرور 10 سنوات عليها لم يستطع
المحققون فك خيوط لغزها الى يومنا هذا
الاسم اليسا اللام المكان لوس انجلوس
امريكا المتهم مجهول
في احد ايام الشتاء البارده في يناير عام
2013 كانت الطالبه الكنديه اليسلام
البالغه من العمر احدى وعشرين سنه في عطله
بمدينه لوس انجلوس الامريكيه استاجرت غرفه
في احد فنادق المدينه الشهيره ويدعى
منذ حجزها للغرفه لم تظهر اليسا في الفندق
الا مره واحده وبعدها اختفت تماما تم
ابلاغ الشرطه عن اختفائها شرطه لوس انجلوس
بشرت البحث عن الشابه لكنها لم تجد اي اثر
لها في المكان
ولدى مراجعتي كاميرات المراقبه وجدوا هذا
التسجيل المريض
ظهرت اليسا وهي تدخل مصعد الفندق وكانت
تضغط عشوائيا على ازرار المصعد ثم تتراجع
بخوف وكان شخصا ما يطاردها
تنظر خارج المصعد ثم تدخل وتنتظر الباب
ليغلق لكن الغريب ان باب المصعد لم يكن
يتجاوب معها وهنا بدا الجزء المرعب من
تسجيل كاميرا المراقبه
الفتاه بدات في تحريك جسدها ويديها في
اشارات غامضه مخيفه وكانها تكلم احدا لم
يظهر في زوايا الكاميرا ثم تخرج من المصعد
لتختفي نهائيا ويعود المصعد للعمل بشكل
طبيعي
[موسيقى]
المفاجاه الاكبر جاءت بعد ثلاثه اسابيع تم
العثور على اليس
الشرطه وجدت الشابه جثه هامده نصف عاريه
في مكان لم يخطر على بالي احد اليسا كانت
داخل خزان مياه محكم الاغلاق على سطح
الفندق
الخزان كان مغلقا بمسامير غليظه بالاضافه
الى عدم وجود سلم للخزان البالغ طوله
مترين ونصف المتر يسمح بالوصول الى قمته
والوصول لسطح الفندق ذاته هو شيء شبه
مستحيل لغير العاملين المختصين
دخلت الشرطه في حاله من الحيره فكيف
استطاعت الفتاه الوصول الى ذلك المكان
المحققون قالوا ان تصرفات اليسا في المصعد
كانت بسبب تاثير المخدرات او الكحول
مرجحين فرضيه انتحاره لكن تقرير الطبيب
الشرعي افاد بعدم العثور على بقايا مخدرات
او كحول في الدم والاغرب عدم العثور على
اي اثر لضرب او مقاومه او عنف او اعتداء
جنسي في الجثه هنا بدات اصوات المؤمنين
بالظواهر الخارقه تتعالى واصابع الاتهام
توجهت مباشره الى الشياطين وقوى الشر وما
عزز تلك المزاعم ان الحادثه لم تكن الاولى
من نوعها في فندق سيسيل
قضيه الامريكيه اليزابيث التي اشتهرت في
الاربعينيات في لوس انجلوس وسميت داليا
السوداء ارتبطت بالقتل والتعذيب والتشويه
الضحيه اقامت ايضا في فندق قبل حادث
مصرعها
الى يومنا هذا لا يزال الغموض يلف الوفاء
ولم يعثر على اي دليل اضافي يقود الى
حقيقه ما حدث لتصنف على انها واحده من
اغرب القضايا الجنائيه في القرن الحادي
والعشرين برايكم هل فعلا هناك قوى خفيه
كانت وراءه وفاه اليسا
[موسيقى]